[Music]
wherever
[Music]
caramina hand caught using the ancient
vela valley method
the fisherman slapped the water to scare
the fish who hide in the lake's muddy
bottom
[Music]
local domestic goddess and food writer
duressie john is going to show me how to
do justice to these slippery blighters
wow okay excellent
how are you i'm very
now the secret behind what we're going
to do take the scales off first yeah
yeah scale is not the way you do it with
your sea bass we're going to slice it
off ready this is how you take it up see
it's coming it's exactly the same way as
the japanese do oh really yeah exactly
the same way normally we just scrape the
skin yeah yeah i know but you can't do
this because the taste of the scales
will remain on that it's not good thing
you need a little more patience i think
garden no no you don't you see you you
have not sliced it see they're so fiddly
yes you're doing it yeah excellent
so your marks are going up now actually
we are supposed to make the gashes on
this
yes
so
yeah yeah that's fine that's fine what
was that another c-plus
finally maybe i'll give you an eight
yeah
i'm learning the locals favorites
caramin polychatu over here is as
popular as our fish and chips
garlickin
first we're making the masala and next
ginger ginger yes yeah i don't need the
whole thing
yeah yeah sure please okay now we'll add
the shallots slots in yeah i believe
we're cooking this on a boat and what we
doing with this are we putting this
inside the fish yeah yeah we are going
to put it around the fish and stuff it
inside the stone right
i think we'll put the tomatoes in
already yeah
well i think chili powder
yes and now we need to put the vinegar
so the vinegar yeah the potato vinegar
and now we are going to make the parcels
right of the fish that stop the fish and
chicken yes i think we just need to put
some here this is the delightful twist
on the french technique on puppy yacht
but instead of steaming the fish inside
a paper bag we're using a banana leaf
and now i'm going to fold it
so you wrap it quite tight yeah we wrap
it rather tight
and how long will they take to cook
about 15 to 20 minutes maximum
this banana parcel keeps all the
moisture and flavor locked in so you're
searing it in yeah
[Music]
that looks fantastic
let's just slide the fish over the bow
look at that
wow
how does it taste
that's delicious
creamy delicious
and i thought it was going to taste
slightly of mud or silk but no it's
fresh it's vibrant and it's very dense
based them into a dover sole but a
little bit sweeter incredibly delicate
thank you wow
that's very good some of the money yeah
yeah yeah
oh jesus where's the kitchen
this is the kitchen this is the kitchen
so we are seriously cooking on the
street yeah
even though his kitchen is rudimentary
manny is a stickler for discipline and
expects his chefs to wear the uniform
manny doesn't care who i am to him i'm
just a lowly commie chef in a street
kitchen and good samba is a
labor-intensive dish
first i'm gonna make the masala or spice
mix for the
sambar manny has his own secret blend of
spices for the masala which gives the
sambar its unique flavor
they've started toasting off the
fenugreek seeds the yellow split peas
coriander curry leaves and then the
chilies
and then they're going to grind it so
we've got this fresh fragrant masala
base for the sambar
ah yeah yeah
it's amazing to think we're in the place
where the film's thumbed up millionaire
davari coconut in good good good sounds
gonna sweeten the masala
coconut in southern indian cuisine is
paramount it's like uh potatoes back in
the uk they play that much importance
now we're gonna cook the lentils yep
okay good
now we begin making the samba itself
take this yeah lentils in
so much effort and care going into
cooking this food it's almost like it's
a fine dining aspect but it's not it's a
vegetarian dish in the middle of a slum
love it love it love it love it now it's
hot
ah manny yeah zed now it's very hot
even though manny is a successful chef
he still lives in a makeshift two-roomed
house
how many do you got to look after in the
family how big is the family 12 people
in this family 12 that's a large family
and is everybody living here yes all of
them live in the same house
keep on walking till he can move i like
that attitude very happy happy with my
shopping
[Music]
[Applause]
it's over 30 degrees and we're now going
up a gear to finish the samba
jesus christ i tell you what
next time i want to run a marathon i'm
going to come back to mumbai and work in
the slum for a day
perfect training this kitchen is like
piccadilly circus
you know it's getting busy now yep was
it tea time traffic
[ __ ]
now i'm going to do the masala paste
this is
putting my spicy sambar masala in is
crucial to give this dish a distinctly
deep flavor
finally we add the lentils
it smells absolutely delicious it's just
become so perfumed and fragrant thank
you
that is delicious
look he knows
all this for 10p a portion
there's not a moment to breathe the
birthday guests have arrived
and manny and i are serving
so what do the guests think
very good
to come and prepare indian food yeah
very nice something very very great
amazing
golden ramsay sambar is very good very
good yummy we hope you all to be here
again i'd love to come back yeah come
back very delicious very fun and amazing
that uh
prepared such a delicious dinner for us
ladies best wishes good night
well
successful
thank you i thought it was going to be
good but i didn't think it was going to
be that spectacular
we are friends till we die exactly that
exactly
thank you huh it's been an absolute
pleasure
pleasure thank you manny's slumdog samba
is the essence of great southern indian
cookery it tastes amazing and costs next
to nothing
being here today was uh
it's quite nerving then when you get out
the car and you start melting in to the
street in a way that you
you work hard to be accepted by them the
minute they see that they connect with
straight away because they are a nation
that
are grafters and samba manny well yeah i
mean he's a
yeah a passionate exciting 50 year old
chef that you know knows his [ __ ]
big time